Hollywood has produced several films
about pandemics now the business itself
is going through one and the disruption
is severe production has come to a
standstill the big summer movie season
is in doubt and some major motion
pictures are skipping theaters and
opening directly in our homes for more
on the impact of all this we're joined
by CBS News contributor Derek Thompson a
staff writer at the Atlantic Derek good
morning to you so even with some states
now lifting restrictions the the
question is will people be ready to go
back to the movies with the fear of the
virus on people's minds and then what do
theater operators need to do to get
people back in those seats well the
short answer to your first question is
that Americans are not ready to go back
to movie theaters in a recent morning
consult poll have found that 69% of
Americans said that they are extremely
unlikely or somewhat unlikely to go back
to movie theaters so you have basically
7 out of 10 people who would go to the
theaters essentially saying I wouldn't
do it right now even if the theaters
were open and that's because a virus
like this a plague like this is a tax on
crowds it's a tax on crowds and movie
theaters and restaurants and sports
stadiums and so those the sort of
businesses that are going to take the
longest to get back to normal when it
comes to you know what can the movie
theaters do well I think they're sort of
two answers that question
one answer is that they can't really do
much unless we get a hold on the disease
itself
do we need to hope that Americans get
healthier that the hospitals begin to
fill - stop being so full and that we
need to have some antiviral drugs that
can bring this under wraps but at the
same time I think what they're talking
about is something like a chess board
seating if you can imagine that kind of
zigzag seating so you don't have people
clustering inside the movie theater
instead you say we're gonna fill it to
25% 30% capacity and we're gonna sit
people in zigzags that nobody is in
there sort of is in the breath line of
somebody else those the sort of measures
you could imagine coming back to movie
theaters the next few months interesting
also now the studios of course Derek in
a major bind reopening Hollywood is
going to be incredibly complicated it's
not just that one side issue or an easy
fix
Warner Brothers for example is now
firmly sticking with this July 17th
release date of Chris
for Nolan's much-anticipated movie tenet
that is just one in particular what's
the risk there well the risk is it is
fairly straightforward
it's that July 17 will come and
Americans will still not want to go to
movie theaters I think the strategic
thinking on Warner Brothers part is we
have this movie from Christopher Nolan
who is the ambassador of the cinematic
experience in a movie theater maybe
we'll get lucky maybe Americans will
feel healthy maybe there'll be weather
effects that reduced the are not or
reproducibility of this disease over the
summer so that it'll have a little bit
of a slowdown in terms of its
transmission and so more Americans might
be able to feel like they can go out to
movie theaters in July and then will own
July and August from a movie theater
perspective because Tennant will be the
only game in town so rather than go to
the movie theaters to see one of 17
shows people will basically be going to
the Tenet theater they'll be going to
see one movie I think that's the bet
that they're making it they can
monopolize that little window of time
this summer when the transmissibility of
the disease will enter a little bit of a
fallow period
hi Derek Michelle here on March 11th
Universal released trolls world tour
across digital platforms a move that
earned the studio nearly a hundred
million dollars in rental fees in just
three weeks
has this force Hollywood to re-examine
their distribution model I think there's
a lot of things right now that are
forcing Hollywood to re-examine the
distribution model and most of it isn't
something that they recognized and last
week it's a bit it's accelerating trends
that pre-existed the pandemic you know
people understood that Americans were
buying fewer tickets to movie theaters
they understood they were spending more
time watching stuff at home and so you
know you saw this explosion of streaming
opportunities and of rental and buying
opportunities just like this I do think
that the experience of trolls and some
other movies might encourage movies
movie studios to sort of pull forward
the future even faster they'll say okay
we're looking at this movie theater
business which has for a century been
the cornerstone of our business but it
won't be the cornerstone for the next
century so how do we find ways to get
our best stuff to people
where they live and that's on their
couch right now a lot of movies I was
looking forward to saying I'm just gonna
have to wait Tarek Thompson thank you